you know life is never what you think is
gonna be young men listen up because
this comes from within me you're not
some mistake that just happened to be if
anyone tells you that God will
definitely disagree this world will
never stop to try and break it down only
those who always stand up again will get
the crown people will let you down not
just cause their Consciousness got
smoked the devil blinded their minds to
see the truth and now they ruin the
lives of especially the youth
I know because I've been where you are
now trying to make sense of the world
but it's hard to Chow demons controlling
political puppets in the shadows causing
most to barely Escape their arrows
[Music]
trying to tell us that good is now evil
and evil is now good that's just
something I never understood as you grow
to understand the world better you'll be
shocked seeing how God's perfect values
are being mocked
that's why I wonder where have all the
good men gone
some are not sure if they can hold out
until the break is dawn
you say well if you can't beat them join
them bro well bro don't you know that's
how your path starts to help alone there
ain't no good coming from Lion stealing
and murdering I'd rather go the other
way because this world needs nurturing
my dad always said there's only one
thing you've got to do only one thing in
this short temporary world worth it to
pursue just give me some time to explain
because in wisdom you need to train
what will help me to gain the whole
world but Lose My Soul nah I'm not one
who wants to die in that Eternal hole
you see I'm about a vapor here and there
my sure life will be gone like a Mist in
the air while I'm here I can't change
the whole world alone but I'm sure going
to try my best to bring it like a
cyclone even if the world is going crazy
without good values now
letting myself become like them I will
never allow you got to stand up for what
you believe in if not evil is going to
play you like a violin you see this
world around you and all there is to
reality you gotta know the devil wants
you to believe in that fantasy making
you focus so hard on only the material
bling that you don't even notice the
Eternal King
yeah I'm talking about your creator
young man that's where all life began
are you ready to meet him when you die
well you know those who live in sin he
will deny time is always fleeting
choosing sin causes a beating
don't be a fool hell ain't cool choose
the light and darkness
won't have a bite